hello everybody i am audrey dubock
product manager at cnb innovations
and today i'm going to talk to you how
to address both sides of the coin and
how micro physical systems can help
better predict safety and efficacy of
novel therapies
so currently scientists have access to a
wide range of tools in a preclinical
toolbox to evaluate new therapeutics and
molecules they usually starts with in
silico assays to really
find the right targets and the right
compounds then we move on to 2d cell
culture and 3d cell culture in vitro
to screen and test and then
when we have more insights you can go
into the in vivo animal studies before
moving on to clinical trials however all
of those toolbox currently raised one
question is how do they translate to the
human and can we make sure that what we
have as a technical data actually works
in the clinic
unfortunately currently most of those
approaches
lead to therapies and molecules failing
clinical trials 90 of the time
we therefore need new approaches to
develop in vitro assays
when developing those assays we do
require a lot of different factors to
consider to really input into the masses
and some of those are first about how
reliable and robust the
new assays what is the cost is it viable
in terms of budget to use the assay and
implement it
can clinically relevant or translational
endpoints be used as well
in the assay what is the throughput
one obviously big important question is
it is it representative of the human
biology
and when working with drugs or compounds
we also need to ensure that it mimics
envy for pharmacokinetics
we need to make sure that we can do
acute and chronic dosing
can you assess the population viability
in that you have more insights
can any immunological effects be added
as well to the assay
and with the trends of new modalities
being more and more being developed and
used such as asos or gene therapy can we
study the effects of such modalities in
those new assays
so one a new technology being recently
developed in the last two decades or
macro physiological systems also called
mps and they usually come in your
pre-clinical toolbox after you've used
2d culture and 3d organoids and before
moving into the in vivo animal studies
what are mps they usually are defined by
being 3d cell cultures typically using
human cells and with the fluid flow used
to mimic the circulatory system either
gravity driven or using true fluidics in
the system
how do those compared to these standard
methods currently using your technical
toolbox
what we know is that humans usually have
human cells they are
composed of 3d complex organ tissues
they have a blood flow connecting these
organs and also inside these organs you
do have an immune system and therefore
you can study human drug exposure so
clinical trials takes out the box
to try to work the drug discovery animal
models like mouse do not offer human
cells because they're different animals
but you do have the complexity of a
whole system and organ and you do have a
blood flow between those organs however
the immune system is very different and
therefore to study the human drug
exposure is very limited
it is also very slow to get results
because you have one condition per
animal
um
conventional assays are a bit faster in
terms of results and they do use human
cells however most of them often offer
immortalized cells so that with the
phenotypes very changed from the
original organ the target
but you do not have 3d complex organ
tissues neither you can have a blood
flow between those organs the immune
system can be sometimes added basically
not fully representative of the human
and the human drug exposure is therefore
not fully assessed in those assay
mps are quite different because they do
offer proper human cells when i say
proper is primary or ipscs you do have
3d complex organ and tissues you can
connect different organs together to
have a blood flow between those organs
the immune system can be also added and
therefore
the human drug exposure when you assess
it in the system is
related to the human and
the clinical data and also the time to
results is also quite fast because you
can have data and answer within two
weeks up to one month when running
experiments
so before i get into really the
applications from this talk today i'm
just going to briefly introduce cnbio
and what we do and why i'm talking to
you about that today
so cn bio commercialized nps devices
and our system the physiomimics was
actually born out of a technological
race that was sponsored by the u.s
defense called darpa between mit and
harvard and we were part of the mit
consortium to develop seven up to ten
organ on a chip
and that race was won by a consortium
back in 2016 and in the back of that we
developed our system the physiomimics
which was launched in 2018 and ever
since its launch had been used with the
fda center for drug evaluation and
research to really assess and evaluate
the use of organ on ship system in
regulatory submissions
and in 2021 we launched our first
multi-organ
physiominx platform with application in
admin toxicology
so here we see the system i'm just going
to briefly introduce it to you as we're
using that system for the different
application covered today and we can see
on the left hand side a big white box
with a touch screen that is a controller
usually sits
outside of the incubator next to it and
controls all of the biology that happens
inside of the incubator
and that biology is performed using the
three plates you see on the right hand
side of the controller here which are
open well architecture and
the flow is driven by the microfluidic
drivers on which they are connected to
enable total perfusion of the biology
inside
the
current platform offers three different
types of plates different to
developed different organ models we do
have a bia plate the transwell t12 that
is used to develop by a model such as
guts longer skin
the liver chip plates which is used to
develop 3d liver models of
either diseased or healthy liver and we
have a transware liver that offers two
organ plates to study the interaction
between the liver and a bio tissue such
as the gut or the lung
so the
experimental design works similarly in
such platform as any kind of cell
culture you first decide on the cell
format you want let it be cell lines or
primary cells themselves or even
commercial models and you're gonna seed
your cells or put your tissue in there
wait for the tissue to be ready
and then start either to induce the
disease states or do repeated drug
dosing over time and we have gone over
30 days using our liver model and the
data are generated from the culture
media the tissue structures and if you
need to
perform some non-invasive measurements
probes can be added into the system
all of the data at the end analyzed
using all the typical endpoint analysis
from omics to microscopy histology
biomarkers and metabolites as well
so now we have done
a bit of an introduction introduction on
the system i'm going to talk to you
about different models of liver mps used
to better predict safety issues um in
the preclinical data
so one of those liver model was
developed in-house and we used our lever
plate the
lc12 you see on the left hand side there
that plate uh inside of its well has
what we called a 3d lever scaffold
it is on the bottom right hand side of
that slide next to the images
and that scaffold has micro channels in
which the cells are seated in the well
and then
the tissue is going to create can be
created over time from signal cells to
micro tissues via morphogenesis and
using a flow that actually circulates
throughout the 3d tissue enabling all of
the cells inside of the 3d structures to
access nutrients and oxygens
the tissue is forming tie junctions so
the peptides are actually polarized and
we also have biochemical eye that are
formed recreating the liver marker
architecture in the plate
we can see here in terms of the balkan
heliculus we do have
a formation of microvilli inside and the
lumen is also there and around the tight
junctions really showing the macro
architecture of the liver inside the
plate the tissue is highly functional
for a long period of time
we can see on the top graph on the right
hand side that albumin is secreted over
time and quite steadily even after 28
days whereas ldh that shows cell death
is quite low showing that tissues are
healthy and functional
they also synthesize a lot of different
proteins like fibrin and fibrinogen a1at
we can measure the expression of a full
range of different seep enzymes and
that's the graft on
at the bottom you can see on the right
where we see a lot of different sip
enzymes being secreted and we can see
the really metabolic activity and the
donor viability when using different
donors
the model is transcriptomically stable
and we do have transporters that we can
assess in the model
the model can be made a bit more complex
adding non-parenchymal cells so we can
add copper cells or stellar cells or
even all of them together to have a
really complex representative model of
the liver
and by doing that here we've tagged the
kerpa cell and stellar cells with egfp
and m cherry just to ensure that we
could see them in the tissue and we can
see that they're all present in there
and when running transcriptomics we can
see that the three cell types all have
the markers there so they're all present
in the cell culture when sitting them
together
we compare that model to the gold
standards currently used in summer
companies which are spirits and to these
sandwich cultures and what we see on the
left graph for the metabolic activity
the liver mps which is in blue has a
much higher and much stable metabolic
activity for a longer period of time
when compared to the sandwich culture
where in yellow we see that after 12
days we have no more metabolic
activities
and ferrites have a steadier longer
metabolic activity but still much much
lower than what we see in liver mps
and we observe a similar trend about
albumin production where we have a much
higher uh production of albumin in liver
mps for a longer period of time compared
to the sandwich culture and the
spheroids
so we use that model internally and or
collaborators as well to assess
drug-induced liver injury
dealing is a very big issue when
developing drugs most of the time it is
detected too late usually in the clinic
or even when a drug reaches the market
which is why we need better in vitro
assets to really assess those risks
before we bring those drugs to the
markets
here we have the example of troglytazone
troglytazone was actually released into
the market in 1997 but was withdrawn
three years later due to some undetected
delay in patients
so we wanted to see if we could recreate
the deliverance for that specific drug
in our system
and for that we used a calculator of
hepatocytes with kept for cells we
did chronic dosing using multiple
endpoints from
seep activity atp ldh albumin we also
use clinical biomarkers here alt
generated ic50 and ec50 curves to
generate an apatotoxins product distance
signature across those multiple
endpoints and what we can see from those
graphs is that we do have a
dose-dependent
genie event happening with proclitizon
where we lose the metabolic activity
these cells are dying because atp is
decreasing alt and ldh are increasing
and we also have a loss of function of
the liver tissues because albumin and
urea are also compromised with it so we
really have a good understanding of what
the genie event is for that drug
we can also
because of that
creates a bit of a
table and decide and determine the
actual delay concern for
drugs using um those different acids and
we can see here on those graphs that the
assay is sensitive enough to really
detect
low to mind levels of hepatotoxicity
on top of the high delay concerns for
drugs that are well known for it so we
can really understand what
the risk is in terms of safety for those
new drugs ahead of time
those liver mps also allow to dig deeper
and try to understand what are the
mechanistic details behind that daily
event and that is done because we can
measure functional seeps transporters
and also the bile acid machinery and all
of those enable the detection of
reactive metabolite toxicity
mitochondrial perturbation cholestatic
injury and also transporter mediated
toxicity
so here we can see the graph on the left
hand side
we can see diclofenac
toxicity over time at different
concentration
and we see mitochondrial perturbation
and calisthenic injury from that graph
we can after that use broad omics
approach to assess the toxicity profile
and here by using proteomic screenings
of secretive proteins we've
identified that the majority of protein
secreted were associated with apoptosis
66 percent of them so really tease out
the difference between different
compound sets and the the deliverance
and the cause of the genie for such
drugs
another
type of safety asset that is quite key
to have better model is genotoxicity
testing
and that is because currently the assays
offer for that or run in vitro and in
vivo all in rats
they do provide high false positive
rates
which is really tricky to interpret
therefore there is a pro correlation
with clinical genotoxicity data so here
the work i'm going to present was
actually developed by our collaborators
at charles river where they developed a
multi-cell type genotoxicity model
incorporating liver and immune cells
using our system
and for that they actually used the
transwell plates also known as the bia
plate in which they used a sandwich
culture of liver endothelial cells
l-sects and hepatocytes at the bottom
of the well
to be directly exposed to the flow and
in the trans wells they actually added
human lymphoblastoid cells so immune
cells tk fix and for those two
different types of cells they have
used two genotoxicity acids that are
internationally recognized and part of
the oecd assets they are mandatory when
assessing um dna damage they use micro
nuclei a
sorry they use micronucleus evaluation
on the immune cells and they used
comet assays to
study the dna strand breakage on the
liver cells
so they used for the liver model either
primary parasites so hepa energy but
here i'm going to present the data on
primary humanopathocytes
so what they've done is to assess
to assess genotoxicity in those liver
models they used indirect mutagens they
are well-studied benzopyrene bap and
cyclophosphamides cp
and they also used direct meteorogen
methane methane sulfinet mms and
ethylmethane sulfonates ems
and what we see here is that
we do observe
for the liver tissue on the top
graph
really a
increase in genotoxicity with those
with those drugs that we couldn't
observe in the rats
and we also see a similar effect for the
macronutrients in evaluation on the tk6
and all of the data they showed here
actually match the clinical data for the
compounds they used so really showing a
good correlation
between
these liver mps models and the clinic
the other side of the cons i mentioned
earlier is to better predict efficacy so
here i'm going to present two types of
mps models first our liver model for
disease modeling and then a lung model
which is quite trending with the with
the pandemic that has been hating us for
the last two years
so the liver model we used was performed
in-house using our standard liver plates
in which we used human uh primary
peptides kept for cells and stellate
cells and we recreated non-alcoholic
fatty liver disease in the plate by
using different fat and sugars in the
media
and we created the different stages of
the disease to really
be able to study the therapeutics of
interest in their
nafld being a huge issue in the western
world with the western diets nowadays it
is something that still has no treatment
because most of drugs failed in efficacy
clinical trials as well
so
how to model nash we use a tri-culture
with these three cell types i've just
mentioned
we can actually measure the inflammatory
profile and we see that the nash model
has an enzymatic profile that is
maintained throughout two weeks we can
see a wide range of cytokines being also
secreted over time and we see a
difference when it's only steatosis
which is hepatitis only
versus the nash phenotypes with the
three different cell types
we can also measure fibrosis in in that
model when
assessing nash and we can measure the
different biomarkers as well express so
fibronectin type one or alpha smooth
muscle actin so we really see a really
nice
spectrum of the whole disease in the
plates
when comparing this model to the current
model of a label on the left hand side
we can see that our model
really compare much better the human
genome genoplast to
compare to the
other models currently accessible
whether let it be in vitro assays on
human emotion lines or actually rats
model
there is also a close association
between human nash and our model we can
see in the venn diagram on the right
hand side on the top
that we do have much more genes
associating with the disease
from human to the mps compared to the
muran model and when comparing the
expression of key genes associated with
human nash
we see that um mps model matches up to
50 of nash patients compared to mural
model going barely to 10 so there is
really a need for those models
to study disease modeling
so once we've established that model was
good enough we wanted to see whether or
not we could recreate the efficacy of
known drugs that were in current that
were in
clinical trials so ela fibrino and
orbital colic acid also known as oca and
we recreated different dosage for the
two drugs to see if we could decrease
the fibrosis phenotype in our model and
what we can see here on the macroscopic
images is we have a dose-dependent
reduction
of the
actual fibrosis
and we can measure that after that and
quantify it in in the liver macro tissue
showing there is an effect that actually
matches
the foundings in phase two clinical
trials for those drugs
another model that has been quite
popular and needed greatly needed in the
last two years was to develop long mps
models so here i'm only going to present
the alveolar model but we do have the
broncolor model as well
so what we've done here is using our
buyer plates using transwells we have
seeded in an air-liquid interface
multiple cell types of the lower airway
including 8182 cells and we calculate
them with endothelium cells and the
endothelial layer is actually seated on
the basolateral side of the trans well
to be directly exposed to the flow in
the plate
what we see from there is we do have a
nice 3d like tissue structure for
northern layer due to the exposition to
the
flow and even our epithelial layer has a
really nice depth and
celiac here and everything looks like
the lung really
the bi integrity is also
much better when the two cell types are
calculated together compared to the
monoculture counterparts as you can see
on the bottom graph
and more importantly we measured the
functional markers for 81 and 82 as
those two cell types tend to
differentiate in vitro we want to see if
we could maintain the phenotype in that
setup and what we see so we do have
still those two cell types in the lung
model really recreating and maintaining
the lung phenotype for the alveolar
model
so we use that model to study viral
infection we could not go with that
studying source cof2 infection as it's
been
on everybody's mind for the last two
years so the way we've done it we used a
pseudotyped antivirus expressing sapco
to spike proteins
and we infected on the apical side we
run a 48 hours infection period we
sampled media of a different type ones
as you can see on the timeline and at
the end we run microscopy to see how
infectious that was
what we see is that after 48 hours on
the on the microscopic images you can
see that
the bottom images
do show infections with suffocation
pseudotype antivirus where we see all
the red in the merged images or actually
infected cells
we've also observed an increase in
disease-specific cytokines where we see
when you have the antivirus there we
have ir6 il1 beta and tnf alpha they're
actually increased over time compared to
the mock where there is no viruses there
and those um
cytokine profiles actually do match the
coveted patients
and
therefore the model mimics covid19
patients profiling for cytokines
once we've established that model we
wanted to see if we could recreate the
inhibition
of the neutralizing antibodies so
the fda approved the release of the
neutralizing antibody as an emergency
treatment for covet patients so we used
that one and that one actually
neutralized the
against the spike receptive binding
domain on on the cove devices and we've
used different dosage of it following
the supplier suggestions and what we see
is on the microscopic images we do have
a dose-dependent response in infecting
lung tissues where we have a lot less
infected tissues and cells in
um in the
sorry in the images where you do see the
treatments when we look at the number of
antivirus fossee counted per images we
do see an infection inhibition that
actually match
the product data sheet supply for this
by the supplier so we do have a soft co2
inhibition response in
the actual
model here
um briefly before we finish it's just
the next step is obviously we are only
working with single organ and as i
mentioned earlier the human body is an
entire connection of different organs
and tissues so we need to make it more
complex to be able to have a full
picture in the pre-clinical toolbox so
this is where multi-yoga and mps come
and you would link the different model
together
and by combining it with pbpk modeling
we hope to better translate in vitro
data to the in vivo and to correlate
that to have a really strong set of data
and this is what we are currently doing
for virus applications so liver and lung
are being currently used in-house to
study the effect of suffocal tube
infection in treatments
um we are moving to liver kidney as well
and hopefully later we'll have more and
more organs connected like that and the
more we know about that the better
understanding of safety and efficiency
we will have before reaching the clinic
so to summarize on all of that
what i want to say is that mps system
closely mimic the human physiology they
are better predictor of human responses
to drugs than current preclinical models
they also generate better in vitro to
individual translation and we do believe
that mps are key to fast-track drug
development and help inherently
reduce the failure rates currently
observed
so before i finish i just want to
acknowledge
the whole team working at cnbio but also
collaborators at mit who did the
groundwork by developing the original
technology and all of our collaborators
from all the different universities and
pharma company and ceos that have worked
with us throughout the years to show you
those data today
so
thank you for listening and i'm looking
forward to your questions